hello everyone this is sami here from
audio science review
i just posted the uh review of the
hifiman
ananda headphone and i thought as a
contrast i also posted a review of the
uh
mass drop or drop focal elex
or alex or elex however it's pronounced
uh on this thing and because there are
very different headphones uh
on this thing this is supposed to be a
close uh
cousin of the focal clear and
i'll show you actually the uh yeah some
comparisons between the two
it's a 700 headphone and you buy it from
drop.com or massdrop.com
even though it's made by focal and i'm
told uh that you can't buy it in europe
i guess focal
uh force dropped only distributed in u.s
uh on this so um i went ahead and
measured it
i found that it was quite easy to
measure on my fixture that the
channel to channel consistency was quite
good and
so was the result in in low and high
frequencies
and you can see that in here you can see
how beautiful the two channels are they
match each other
almost perfectly and we more or less
follow a preference curve
between 100 hertz and about three
killers
below 100 hertz we have this drooping
response
and certainly not flat and certainly not
what uh let you know latest research in
preference tells us that you know you
want to achieve this
this blue curve there's a bit of excess
energy in here but i find that the
accuracy is not quite
that high in the preference curve in
here a little bit of wiggleness which
i'll cover
and then there's a short file right in
here
uh on this otherwise you know the peaks
more or less line up with our preference
in high frequencies there are a lot of
reflections inside the cup
and causes dips and and peaks in here so
you want to look at the
envelope the peaks of these things
rather than the ups and downs in here
these things are not
material so for grins i went out there
and went ahead and
pulled up the uh measurements i did of
the for calculator
and boy they look identical yes there's
some channel to channel variation but
that could have been that the
pads had worn differently on on the
clear that i tested
and you can see even the wiggliness in
here matches the wiggliness in here
the curve is just as identical as it
gets you know relative to
you know headphone measurements on on
this thing so
uh that tells me that basically there
are close cousins of each other
um that's basically tonality should be
identical between the two
uh even for cal utopia has a very
similar
signature in here if you look at these
two for example
very little is different up to here in
high frequencies though there is some
difference between the two so
you know maybe a tonality changes in in
treble area
but up to treble uh looks similar and
that tells me that focal has some
in standard internally some frequency
response
curve that they're trying to follow and
and they think this is the right one
my opinion this is not correct in base
response
um so that's same thing showing the
frequency response relative to our
preference
and basically shows that we we need a
lot more bass than we have
group delay as i've explained before you
want to have an exponential drop-off to
zero in here
any kind of wiggliness and a messiness
tends to increa
suggest that there are multiple sources
of sound they're interfering with each
other
and we tend to get them in in this
region
a lot more with some headphones than
others these uh focals have a
angle driver uh you're not gonna build
symmet in in here
and uh that may couple to your ear in a
special way that causes this kind of
wiggliness
um one of the members on the forum is
suggesting that the nice spatial
effects you get where the sound is
opened or layered comes maybe
uh because of the let me put this way
that we see the indication of it through
this messiness so this
messiness max should be a good thing so
i've been noting that
and we'll see where it goes as usual
whenever you see these massive peaks and
valleys in here the the sharp ticks you
do not want to eq that that tells you
that there's
definitely cancellation or additions
happening so don't touch that area with
any kind of equalization
um when i tested the focal clear i found
that as soon as i turn up the volume
especially with my equalization
it also would make the nastiest
crackling sound that
you makes you think that you just blew
the headphone or your ear trunks or both
uh on this thing and this time i under a
lot of debates as to whether it does it
or not
this time when i was running the sweeps
on on elex
i noticed that actually at 114 db spl it
was crackling all the way as it was
sweeping
uh i don't know if it's all the way but
i could hear it crackling
as this thing was mounted on a fixture i
could hear from the outside so
for sure this headphone just like claire
can't handle
loudness below above certain level now
you might think well
you know 114 db is quite loud um that's
never going to happen
it actually based 114 db is not very
loud i'll do a video on it
in the future um and indeed on real
music without a lot of bass
uh female vocals for example with my
equalization
as i turn up the volume all sudden i
would hear the crackling sounds so very
ungraceful
uh on that front um and you can see that
the clear
had the same problem here so both of
these headphones are
are good but above that and especially
if you stay at the
94 and 140 db spl which is these two
graphs
at the bottom look at how low the
distortion is it basically hugs the zero
line uh extremely low distortion
uh if it's just nothing to speak of even
at 114 whereas crackling at low
frequencies
at high frequencies is extremely clean
i just posted a review of hifiman and
under and so many people claim it's just
the best thing they've heard but let's
do a quick comparison distortion there
look at what it produces in here there's
just
no way one can make a case that this
ananda haifa manananda hernandez
producing clean sound
it's just not even in the same planet we
have like four percent distortion
uh at the highest level uh in here in
in the most sensitive region of our
hearing which is one to two kilohertz
and another one over here
so going back to elex again uh you can
see there's just neck
i mean there's just none of it there so
very very very clean and
and that's just a nice thing to have and
same with clear clear was also very
clean
uh there are some variations in low
frequency by the way due to fit
and stuff like that so don't micro
analyze this thing just look at the
trends
which in this case just as frequencies
go up this is one clean driver
um at 94 db i showed that it's just
really just
everything below 200 is just a little
bit above my threshold
but above that you can see actually a
nice gap develops in here where we have
this
distortions down here and the signal is
way up here so
very very clean headphone the impedance
of this headphone is very variable at
one kilohertz is only 81 ohms
but in low frequencies jumps all the way
up to 290 ohms
and because of that 290 ohms you need to
have a lot of voltage to drive that's
not
not current low impedance
headphones need current and a lot of
phones for example don't produce a lot
of voltage and so they may have some
difficulty driving this fortunately
it's a very sensitive headphone uh you
can see it's 180 millivolts it takes to
produce 94 db
and that's uh you know about 40 50 less
than sennheiser hd 650 which requires
288 millivolts
so as as sensitivity goes efficiency
goes
is in the middle to you know better than
middle
uh on this so which is an advantage you
know you could wind up with headphones
up here where you just
absolutely dedicated desktop amplifiers
to drive them well
you don't need that with with this
although it's not way down here either
on uh listening test um
it's good news bad news a lot of
headphones that have bad frequency
response i can't even listen to them
without equalization
in this case there was no glaring fault
with the sound
i just found that it wasn't exciting i
mean you're in this hobby to get
exciting sound when you play a reference
track you want to just put give you
goosebumps and it didn't give me
goosebumps
so but just a couple of filters one over
here
you know filling in that hole around
four kilohertz
and anything in this region when you
raise it up actually opens up the sound
and makes the spatial qualities better
and so i'm always happy when i can boost
that up and especially when it's a low
distortion headphone meaning when i do
this the distortion doesn't increase
to counteract that and then i dialed in
some amount of
sub-bass uh enhancement and bass
enhancement this is just done by eye
both of these are done by eye by the way
i don't use any kind of computer program
to spit them out
and i then do listening tests i do a b
tests and sometimes blind a b test where
i turn these bands on and off
individually
and make sure that the effect is a
noticeable and and be
uh add to the experience and across all
the tracks that i tested
this boost makes an amazing difference
because this this headphone is so low
distortion it's able to take a lot of
equalization without any side effects
and once i had these two together it was
just
extremely nice sounding headphone uh
it's not like hd800s and others that
have these massive spatial effects
but it's got enough of that magic in
there to make you feel good about it and
then
tonality is nice now usually when a
headphone just takes a couple filters
like this i would give it
my highest you know award which is the
golfing panther or the
in case of european stuff of the soccer
player panther
uh in here i just couldn't do that again
because i literally was afraid of
turning up the volume
unless they start to crackle in my ear i
mean this is not
minor you know where the sound gets
little distortion also
sounds like somebody's taking like a
piece of mylar and crackling it
uh luckily it's not that and the driver
seems quite robust
uh but uh but it's it's quite annoying i
i mean again i could hear it even on
female vocals once i boosted the bass
this much to get proper sub bass
then it happens a lot more uh was the
volume high
yeah relatively speaking but i'm the
kind of person when once in a while
there's
good music and i said wow that sounds
good i want to crank it up for just the
you know minute or two listening to that
and then
turn it back down so it's not a case
where i sit there constantly listen at
that high volume
and i don't want any limitations in the
device that i'm using especially since
their competitors don't have these
limitations
so in this case simplex focals made a
trade-off
in that they made an extremely low
distortion driver
but but it can't go past certain amount
of uh
excursion you just push it just a hair
and it just something flexes or
something bad happens in that driver
where distortion just shoots up through
the roof and
and the thing starts to crack off so if
you can stay below that
limit then it's an extremely good
headphone
and 700 is a cheap way to get into
this headphone versus paying more for
the true
clear brand that said later on in the
forum discussion
a number of people post that these
headphones reliability has been quite
poor
where after a certain amount of time
year or so
or sometimes a month after they get it
one channel cuts out
and the drivers literally goes bad and
your only warranty is through drop.com
and they only provide that warranty
through their
uh you know one year warranty i think
they provide they've been good
apparently in extending that a little
bit for people but
uh people post that this is a common
problem with these things and
it's a shame if that's the case um
for sure if you get it use it a lot
during the warranty period to make sure
that doesn't happen
um so but if you're worried about that
and if the clear version of it is better
then
go ahead and get the clear version and
you'll see that my equalization is
similar for both of them and
and it should do the same thing again
the crackling will be there just to say
um
but at least this reliability issue will
not be there
uh sort of makes sense that maybe for
cal found a
way to use cheaper drivers that maybe
they're not
tested for as long for you know
infant mortality or some other issue
that's something that they do
and bid them or yeah for their own brand
but when they sell it under the drop
name uh some corners may have been taken
i don't know i just thought i'd give you
that warning if that bothers you then
there are plenty of other headphones to
go pick
go to audiosensereview.com and and look
at all the headphone drivers and you'll
find a lot of other choices
okay that's it see you in a future video
bye